[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo da sind wir wieder hier ist der
zweite Teil einer wirklich ganz wilden
Hochstapler Geschichte ich bin Toni
Heyer und mit mir ist wie immer der
Liebe Mirko Kasimir hallo Mirko hallo
Toni grüß Dich hallo hier ist Mirko wir
sind wieder mit euch in Berlin in
Köpenick am 16 oktober 1906 hierhin hat
der vorbestrafte schumachermeister
Wilhelm Vogt gerade gut zehn
soldatenbauordert der unterwegs mit der
unerschütterlichen Autorität eines
Hauptmanns der in Wahrheit natürlich
nicht ist unter seinen Kommando gestellt
Vogt hat die Faxen dicke vom Staat und
will der Obrigkeit eins auswischen er
hat zwar ganz eindeutig eine
Vergangenheit als Kleinkrimineller aber
Vogt hat seine Strafen längst abgesessen
und gezeigt dass er sich mit
ordentlicher Arbeit über Wasser halten
kann aber die Polizei vertreibt ihn
immer wieder mit sogenannten
aufenthaltsverboten erst aus Mecklenburg
dann aus Rixdorf bei Berlin und heute
rechtes Leben als er mit den
zusammengetrommelten Soldaten in
Köpenick ankommt drückt er jedem der
Soldaten eine Mark in die Hand damit sie
in der Gaststätte des Bahnhofs essen
können dann erst erklärt er Ihnen worin
der Befehl von allerhöchster Stelle
eigentlich besteht wir werden den
Bürgermeister und vielleicht noch andere
Herren verhaften ja und so kommt es der
Trupp marschiert zum Rathaus von
Köpenick und erobert das Gebäude im
Sturm allerdings völlig gewaltlos den
Gendarm im Rathaus befiehlt er die
Umgebung abzusperren und für Ruhe und
Ordnung zu sorgen und einen der
Gendarmen lässt er sich sogar direkt als
ortskundigen Helfer abstellen und jetzt
noch ein weiterer komischer Aspekt denn
der Chef der Köpenicker Polizei der
ebenfalls im Haus ist der bekommt von
Wilhelm Vogt für den Rest des Tages
Urlaub und geht nach Hause um ein Bad zu
nehmen
klar also wenn der Befehl Urlaub lautet
dann wird auch Urlaub basta
auf jeden Fall wird das Rathaus
abgeriegelt und den Anwesenden Beamten
und Besuchern wird jeglicher Aufenthalt
auf den Fluren verboten anschließend
verhaften sie Bürgermeister Georg
langerhands und oberstadtsekretär
Rosenkranz angeblich im Namen seiner
Majestät und wegen Veruntreuung der
Bürgermeister ist natürlich ziemlich
überrascht weiß von nichts und verwahrt
sich gegen die Vorwürfe der verständlich
diese Vorwürfe sind ja auch völlig aus
der Luft gegriffen aber dass der
Bürgermeister alles abstreitet eine
schriftliche Legitimation und weitere
Informationen verlangt das wirkt
natürlich auf die Soldaten wie eine
absehbare Reaktion eines ertappten
Gauners der auch inzwischen hat sich
auch herumgesprochen dass da irgendwas
im Gange ist im Rathaus vor dem Haus hat
sich eine riesige Menschenmenge
versammelt
Gerüchte machen die Runde aber niemand
weiß etwas genaues tja wie auch drin
geht alles inzwischen seinen geordneten
bürokratisch preußischen Gang der
falsche Hauptmann beschlagnahmt erstmal
die Stadtkasse natürlich gegen Quittung
wo kennen wir denn sonst sind also es
werden Beamte zum Postamt geschickt denn
ein Teil des Geldes wurde auf der Bank
eingezahlt und muss nun abgehoben werden
schließlich muss alles seine Richtigkeit
haben und die Kasse für die
vermeintliche Ermittlung vollständig
sein alles läuft sehr geregelt und
penibel und man stellt fest dass die
Kasse eine Mark 67 weniger enthält als
sie laut den Büchern sollte das wären
heute so um die 12 Euro dem Hauptmann
von Mahlzeiten alias Wilhelm Vogt dem
kam diese Tatsache natürlich ordentlich
gelegen denn so konnte er sagen hey
schaut mal es ist wirklich was faul im
starte Dänemark kein Wunder dass der
Bürgermeister nach Legitimationen und
schriftlichen befehlen
und erkrakehlt nicht lange denn Vogt
lässt ihn und den kassenbart in eine
drosch gesetzten und unter Bewachung
durch einen gardefiselier und einen
Köpenicker Polizisten zur neuen Wache in
Berlin kutschieren dort werde man sie
weiter Verhören da werden sie erst mal
eine Weile unterwegs sein und genau
darum geht es vor natürlich er will Zeit
schinden dazu hat er auch das Postamt
für Telefonate sperren lassen so dass
niemand in Berlin nachfragen oder die
Gefangenen ankündigen kann seinen
Soldaten gibt er die Anweisung das
Rathaus noch eine Stunde zu sichern
in einer Stunde ziehen Sie die Portal
waren ein marschieren zum Bahnhof fahren
nach Berlin und melden in ihren Kasernen
von Köpenick zurück
hier haben Sie Geld für die Rückfahrt
vom restkurs für jeden Mann in der
bahnhofswirtschaften das Bier und eine
Bockwurst
ihr selbst aber verlässt das Gebäude mit
3.557 Mark und 47 Pfennigen das wären
heute ungefähr 25.000 Euro und damit
spaziert er durch die Menschenmenge zum
Bahnhof Köpenick und lässt sich dort ein
Glas helles kredenzen dass er in einem
Zuge lehrt wie es in den späteren
Zeitungsberichten heißt
Bierchen hat er sich auch verdient mit
dem nächsten Zug fährt der unbehelligt
naja so unbehelligt man nach einem
hellen auf Exem sein kann
aber wirklich 5 € in die wortspielkasse
okay er ist schon gut also er fährt
jedenfalls nach Berlin zurück und das
vorerst letzte was man vom Hauptbahnhof
sieht das ist der größte Teil seiner
Uniform die finden nämlich Passanten auf
dem Tempelhofer Feld in der neuen Wache
zu Berlin gibt es unterdessen ordentlich
Verwirrung als eine Droschke den
Bürgermeister und dem Kassenwart von
Köpenick zur weiteren befrag ung auf
höchstem Befehl abliefert denn natürlich
sind hier alle ahnungslos und wissen
nicht was sie mit den beiden Gefangenen
anstellen sollen aber sehr schnell wird
klar das ist ja ein Hochstapler wirklich
großes Ding durchgezogen hat
preislichkeit sieht
die Geschichte wird sofort zur riesen
Sensation es erscheinen Extrablätter und
erst lacht ganz Berlin dann ganz
Deutschland und nach wenigen Tagen die
ganze Welt über diesen Hauptmann von
Köpenick und seinen genialen Q ja sogar
der Kaiser lacht mit also angeblich dass
es nicht verbirgt angeblich ruft er da
kann man sehen was Disziplin heißt kein
Volk der Erde macht uns das nach naja
wenn er gesagt hat war es sicher
ironisch gemeint wäre schon komisch aus
dieser Story den Schluss abzuleiten dass
unbedingt die Disziplin eine tolle Sache
ist verbirgt ist das Wilhelm II den
falschen Hauptmann als genialen Kerl
bezeichnet hat Wilhelm Vogt genießt
seinen Triumph in einer Wohnung in der
Nähe des schlesischen Bahnhofs das ist
der heutige Ostbahnhof in Berlin doch
die typierte Staatsmacht ist ihm auf den
Fersen eine Belohnung von 3000
Reichsmark wird ausgesetzt das ist fast
so viel wie Wilhelm Voigt erbeutet hat
und nach Zeugenaussagen werden
Steckbrief erstellt die bald an allen
Liter sollen kleben darin heißt es unter
anderem der Täter der schmale weiße
Hände hat ist auffallend hässlich naja
das könntest du heute jetzt nicht mehr
so schreiben ja mit Sicherheit nicht im
übrigen ich habe mir ein paar Fotos
angeschaut von ihm und okay hübsch war
jetzt nicht wirklich aber ja das Spiel
doch Schönheit liegt im Auge des
Betrachters okay da hast du natürlich
vollkommen Recht ja da war Heinz Rühmann
in seiner Rolle als Hauptmann von
Köpenick schon sehr schmeichelhaft für
den historischen wilhelm-fucht aber ist
ja auch ein Film ne andererseits kann es
aber nicht ganz so schlimm gewesen sein
denn neben dem Bürgermeister hatte ja
auch dessen anwesende Ehefrau zeitweilig
festgesetzt und die ja die war wohl
ziemlich angetan von ihm nicht unbedingt
von seiner Schönheit aber von seinem
militärischen schneit und seiner
Autorität und davon dass er zwar mit
ihrem Mann äußerste ruppig umsprachen
sie aber mit ausgesuchter Höflichkeit
behandelt hat eben einen echter Kavalier
ja ja ein Offizier und Gentleman also
ich kann mir vorstellen dass der
Haussegen danach beim Bürgermeister
ziemlich schief gegangen hat keine
Kombination Toni das ist reine
Spekulation Wilhelm Voigt jedenfalls
kann seinen gelungenen Kuh nicht lange
genießen denn zehn Tage nach seiner
Köpenick Jade wird er beim Frühstück
verhaftet ein ehemaliger Zellengenossen
hat ihn verraten der wusste von
vogtsplänen und war scharf auf die
Belohnung ja und dass dieser
gefängniskumpel ein gewisser Kallenberg
von diesen Plänen wusste scheint doch
daraufhin zu deuten das Vogt schon vor
der Entlassung plante wieder straffällig
zu werden und das ist nicht die fiese
Behandlung eines geläuterten Verbrechers
durch die nachtragende Staatsmacht war
die ihn zu dieser Tat drängte aber auch
das ist reine Spekulation genauso gut
könnte es auch sein dass er ganz genau
wusste welche behördlichen Schikanen
ihnen Freiheit erwarten würden und
deshalb einfach einen Plan B parat haben
wollte
Wilhelm Vogt jedenfalls wird vor dem
Landgericht zwei in Berlin wegen
unbefugten tragen seiner Uniform des
Vergehens wieder die öffentliche Ordnung
der Freiheitsberaubung des Betrugs und
der schweren Urkundenfälschung angeklagt
wir haben in seiner Verteidigung da
stützt er sich ganz auf die Behauptung
man habe ihm keine Wahl gelassen und
eigentlich habe er nur einen
auslandspass erbeuten wollen das Geld
habe er nur zur Verwahrung an sich
genommen also man habe es ihm förmlich
aufgedrängt und selbstverständlich hätte
er es später zurückgegeben ja
selbstverständlich tatsache ist das Vogt
während der Besetzung des Rathauses
überhaupt nicht nach Hessen suchte
sondern sich ganz auf die Kasse
konzentrierte denn er vermutete darin
statt magerin 3000 und ein paar
zerquetschten das hübsche sümchen von
zwei Millionen Reichsmark was eine
heutigen Summe von fast 14 Millionen
Euro gleich käme
ja damit ließe sich schon was anfangen
ne also die Geschichte von den Millionen
im Köpenicker Tresor die hat vermutlich
auch schon während seiner Haftzeit
gehört aber wie auch immer das Publikum
im Gericht liebt ihn die zahllosen
internationalen Presse Leute die lieben
ihn auch und der Richter der meint es
auch gut mit dem inzwischen
weltberühmten Angeklagten Wilhelm Vogt
wird zu vergleichsweise milden vier
Jahren Gefängnis vorurteilt und nach
nicht einmal zwei Jahren von einem
seiner Fans niemand geringerem als
Kaiser Wilhelm den zweiten begnadigt und
macht sich nur stracks daran seine
Geschichte zu formalen
gleich am Tag nach der Verhaftung macht
er eine Grammophon Aufnahme und erhält
dafür 200 Mark und dank dieser Aufnahme
können wir jetzt auch mal kurz die wahre
Stimme des Hauptmanns vom Köpenick hören
meine Damen und Herren seine persönliche
Person sondern durch seine Stimme zu
Ihnen sprechen so glaube ich bis zu
nichts dafür verpflichtet dir die vielen
Beweise die sie während des letzten
schweren lieb während dieser oder jeder
Form gefunden haben weil
klebt ein gutes Leben genießt die
Berühmtheit und verdient wohl mehr als
er in Köpenick geraubt hat unter anderem
landet eine Wachsfigur von ihm im
Kabinett von Madame Tussauds ja denn wie
gesagt er ist weltberühmt überall auf
der Welt lacht man über seinen Streich
und die Einfältigen deutschen am
lautesten natürlich in Deutschland
selbst über unsere unkritische Disziplin
unsere Obrigkeit unseren Untertanen
Geist und man muss natürlich sagen das
waren alles Wichtige Tugenden
wilhelminischen Berlin oder Untugenden
trifft es vielleicht noch ein bisschen
besser die ihre schlimmste Ausprägung
natürlich im Dritten Reich erfuhren aber
ging es in dieser Geschichte wirklich
darum
ich würde sagen eher nicht also aus
militärischer Sicht ist absolut nichts
auszusetzen wenn Soldaten Befehlen
folgen natürlich auch nicht pauschal du
hast es gerade schon angesprochen im
Dritten Reich das darf man da auch nicht
mit reinziehen also eine gewisse
Differenziertheit gehört auch mit dazu
das Problem waren aber hier nicht die
Befehle des Problem war dass es Vogt
gelungen war die Soldaten zu täuschen
und ihnen eine falsche Identität
vorzugaukeln ja und das hatte durchaus
sehr geschickt gemacht denn jede
erfolgreiche Hochstapler oder Betrüger
muss auch ein bisschen psychologisch
sein denn hätte Vogt die Soldaten gleich
zu Anfang damit konfrontiert dass sie
mit der S-Bahn fahren mit dem Vorort Zug
und einen 8 km Marsch nach Köpenick
machen um dort den Bürgermeister zu
verhaften und die Stadtkasse zu
konfiszieren dir dann alleine
wegschaffen wolle tja vielleicht wäre
den Soldaten dann aufgefallen dass eine
Kordel an der Uniform nicht ganz stimmt
und dass der vermeintliche hauptmann
allerhöchsten Befehlen statt seines
Helmes nur eine Mütze trug ja aber vor
klockte Sie Schritt für Schritt in die
Falle erstmal sollten Sie nur Meldung
machen und ein paar Fragen zu ihren
Befehlen beantworten etwas was keinen
Art von denkt falsche Kordel hin
fehlender Helm her aber es war bereits
eine Anerkennung der Autorität und jeder
weitere Schritt also jeder weitere
Gehorsam viel umso leichter klar wir
latschen im Gleichschritt zum Bahnhof
okay wir fahren mit der Bahn zu einem
Einsatz alles klar oh ein Bier das ist
mein cooler Vorgesetzter na klar
verhaften wir den Bürgermeister und
damit wurde es nicht nur erleichtert zu
gehorchen sondern auch immer schwerer zu
widersprechen oder gar den Hauptmann den
angeblichen Hauptmann in Frage zu
stellen sie steckten mittendrin sie
hatten bereits ihrem eigentlichen
Auftrag zur Kaserne zurück zu
marschieren zu wieder gehandelt sie
wollten glauben sie mussten glauben dass
das alles mit guten Dingen zugeht ja und
unser Gehirn das ist ziemlich gut darin
unerwünschte Informationen und Zweifel
einfach auszublenden die Geschichte ist
ja voll von solchen Stories über
Betrüger und Hochstapler in aller Welt
von der Antike bis hin in die Gegenwart
also von falschen Piloten Ärzten
Heiratskandidaten und Propheten aller
Art und nun mal so als Beispiel ein
erfolgreicher Betrüger auf einer
Dating-Plattform tja der wird auch nicht
in der ersten Nachricht schreiben dass
er Geld braucht der wird seine Opfer
langsam in einem Netz aus Lügen
Einspänner wird sie einlollen immer
wieder Gutes tun und ihr Vertrauen
erringen bevor er sie dann irgendwann
ausnimmt egal was man glaubt sich zu
kennen oder was auch immer so wirklich
sicher ist niemand vor sowas weil
Menschen können wirklich gut eine Maske
tragen
Wilhelm Voigt genoss sein Leben als
Berliner Größe noch einige Jahre
arbeitete später als Kellner und
tatsächlich auch als Schumacher und
starb zu guter okay oder zu schlechter
letzten 1922 verarmt in Luxemburg aber
seine Geschichte die lebt weiter wurde
wieder und wieder erzählt und verfilmt
zum Beispiel 1956 von Helmut koitner mit
Heinz Rühmann in der Hauptrolle und aus
diesem Film haben wir einige Ausschnitte
verwendet eine große Hilfe beim
Schreiben dieser Episoden waren außerdem
Artikel im Spiegel und auf der Webseite
der Gesellschaft für Sicherheitspolitik
e.V
[Musik]
www.gsp-ipop.de sowie die Episode the
rock dressed at the capton des Podcasts
korschenary Tales with time harford
schön dass er diesmal wieder mit dabei
wart und hoffentlich hören wir uns schon
ganz bald wieder und dann wird es ja
auch mal wieder ein bisschen ernster bis
dahin macht 's gut euer Wirkung und eure
Toni